Ukrainian President Vladimir zielinski
is in Canada today the first time in
fact that he's visited this country
since the Russian invasion now zielinski
will speak to the Canadian Parliament
before traveling to Toronto for an
evening program but the first event for
the Ukrainian president is a meeting
with the governor general Mary Simon at
Reno Hall and that is where we find our
chief political correspondent David
Aiken this morning hello David so
obviously uh late night and a busy day
for president zielinski and one assumes
for the Prime Minister what's that's
going to happen today
yeah it's been a busy week actually for
both men they've been uh out of the
country in the United States prime
minister Trudeau has been at the U.N in
New York City for the last few days uh
Vladimir zielinski spoke to the U.N and
then he was in Washington meeting with
uh Folks at the White House yesterday
they're both here now getting in on
separate flights last night and as you
mentioned I'm here at Rideau hall
because as per protocol the head of
state of Ukraine that would be president
zielinski is meeting the representative
of our head of state and that's the
governor general Mary Simon so it's a
quick protocol visit and then really all
the activity is going to be down on
Parliament Hill here in Ottawa the Prime
Minister and the president will have a
one-on-one meeting then members of the
Canadian cabinet will join in as well
Ukrainian president zielinski has
brought his defense minister here and so
there are some meetings between the two
defense ministers the speech that
zielinski will give to Parliament
happens or scheduled to happen about 1
pm eastern time it's the second time
that zielinski has addressed the
Canadian Parliament but the last time he
did it and was just after Russia invaded
in February of 2022 uh he did it via
video link because then there was still
very much issues around his own personal
security whether he could leave the
country it's a better security situation
now in Ukraine it's of course there's
still a war going on but that's why
president zerlenski is able to be in
Ottawa uh himself here uh and then there
will be a quick chat with some reporters
take some questions both Trudeau and
zelenski and then off to Toronto to meet
with members of the Ukrainian community
and there is a big Ukrainian community
in Toronto mostly based in Etobicoke
there's one of the highest
concentrations of ukrainians in the
country and I know they'll all be
excited to see um solenski this evening
so let's talk more about an elaborate if
you could on the purpose of this trip
obviously a whirlwind tour for the
Ukrainian president you mentioned the
Ukrainian diaspora in many ways I mean
the one point symbolically important for
the 1.3 plus million uh ukrainians at
least Ukrainian Canadians in this
country but also politically and
economically talk about I guess what he
hopes to uh yield from this
well in in addition to fighting a real
war with the Russians right now
zielinski is essentially engaging in a I
wouldn't call it diplomatic War but
diplomatic campaigns diplomatic missions
all around the world to continue to seek
economic aid and military aid from
Ukraine's allies and certainly that is
one of the reasons he is here today
Canada has already contributed about
five billion dollars in economic aid one
and a half billion dollars in military
aid but zolenski is going to ask for
more and Canada to the degree it has the
money and we are a wealthy country we do
have the money do we have more military
aid that we can give we all know our
military was suffering from its own
Supply problems and equipment problems
do we have some more to give to the
Ukraine so we will hear more about that
Canada has been absolutely a staunch
Ally of Ukraine throughout this war
there's really no wavering among any
political Party conservatives Or
democrats the block liberals of course
are all structurally behind Ukraine in
this effort and I would expect
presidents Lindsay is going to get a
very warm reception when he steps into
the House of Commons chamber this
afternoon so you mentioned the military
aid billions of dollars that Canada has
given and you wonder how sustainable
that is in the long term and how
politically um Salient it is in this
country to continue that support because
we're seeing in the United States for
example there is some resistance to some
of the money being given or being
offered at least talk about that if you
can and where that could lead
to other countries perhaps even in
Canada
yeah I think right now zielinski's real
issue is with the United States and he's
just come from the White House the U.S
President Joe Biden is ready to help out
Ukraine Democrats in the Congress are
ready to help Ukraine Republicans in the
Senate by and large are ready to give
Ukraine what it needs but there's a lot
of Republicans in the Congress that
that's it they don't want to give
Ukraine any more money or military aid
and um and that is going to be a problem
the United States is is heads in a way
the largest contributor of Aid both
economically and militarily to Ukraine
but even beyond that as I mentioned
zielinski's got this sort of diplomatic
Mission campaign if you will right now
there's an election in Slovakia and the
leading candidate in that election has
said if he wins that's it no more
support for Ukraine Poland which has
been very much helping out Ukraine it's
right next door Poland has said no more
weapons for Ukraine because there is a
big dispute about agricultural Imports
Ukrainian grain going into into Poland
right now displacing polish Farmers so
until that disputes resolved Poland is
not going to be be giving any more money
and and weapons to Ukraine so there's a
lot of fires zelinski's got to put out
on the Diplomatic front in order to get
the weapons that he needs uh to fight
off Russia where does Canada fit in all
that as zielinski the phrase zolenskies
has said to Canada to prime minister
Trudeau we need your diplomatic muscle
Canada is a G7 member a G20 member we
get into clubs that Ukraine can't get in
and zelenski very much counts on prime
minister Trudeau advocating for Ukraine
internationally as I said because there
are some there are some softening
softening support for Ukraine in many
capitals around the world and the
conflict as no end Insight so we
appreciate the update David I know
you're going to have a busy day as well
that is David Akin joining us from Rito
Hall just outside thank you sir